par contre ce qui est rigolo c'est que
quand on triche et qu on fait juste s'en
fait le roi ici ici sa paire est ici
s'appelle en fait ça là j'ai mélangé
pour toi et moi je met un rouge est
barré par ses pertes
[Musique]
salut vous l'avez remarqué c'est l'euro
tour le grand retour du tricheur sur la
chaîne maurice d'où là en fait on fait à
peu près une vidéo par ensemble au mois
d'avril mois peuvent néanmoins il ya un
truc dont on n'a jamais parlé ensemble
c'est du jeu ultime des tricheurs a vite
fait parler une fois mais jamais trop
n'a jamais parlé du bonneteau est ce que
tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est la
première fois que tu as vu du bonneteau
nous écoutons maurice de dafniah la
première fois j'ai vu du bonneteau
c'était dans la rue avait que 14 15 ans
mais là en fait je les revues il ya peu
de temps au pied de la tour eiffel et
j'ai encore vu des gens se faire
arnaquer c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
tant parler et faire une vidéo avec toi
là dessus pour prévenir les gens ne
jouais pas pour prévenir ou pour montrer
que tu peux nous arnaquer bah je peux
montrer que je peux vous avez évident
alors le bonneteau ckoi attention point
historique
loïc générique de points historiques go
donc le bonneteau c'est quoi le
bonneteau ça se jouait à l'époque et ça
se joue toujours avec en fait trois
cartes d'accord donc deux jokers et un
roi donc l'idée c'était de tendre un
petit peu les cartes comme ça on va le
faire vraiment à l'ancienne d'accord ok
va bien donc tu vois ici on a le roi le
roi rouge d'accord ici on a les jokers
et on mélange donc pour toi c'est
évident où est le roi tu as vu toujours
me when the l'année dernière et ça ouais
par contre ce qui est rigolo c'est que
quand on triche et qu on fait juste s'en
fait le roi ici ici sa paire est ici
sapeurs ont fait ça là j'ai mélangé pour
toi il est où moi je mets pas un rond
ici et ben ouais et ben c'est perdu et
après tu as aimé là mais moi je dois
donc voilà donc là j'ai village est
riche et clairement il que la paix tout
ça est en fait qui marrant c'est de se
dire que malgré tout comme les gens
pensent toujours avoir une chance sur
trois est plus malin il pense toujours
suivre il ya toujours des gens pour le
après il ya une mécanique il faut venir
quelqu'un qui commence à gagner
ça le baron etc alors en fait il ya même
si c'est même plus que ça en rugby il ya
le bonheur c'est cela qui manipulent les
cartes et autour il n'y a pas un il ya
des barons quoi c'est l'action vraiment
à plusieurs ils sont quatre ou cinq est
en fait l'argent circule entre eux ah
oui d'accord ok tu vois ce que j'ai dit
je te file 50 euros etc
moi j'ai une grosse pièce dans la main à
manger tu parais tu sais où est la carte
hop tu gagnes et là là évidemment vous
arriver et vous fait avoir il suffit
d'une personne pour la journée alors un
peu d'histoire ça remonte à quand en
fait quand est-ce que ça a été créé je
crois que ça remonte à fin c'est
vraiment très très loin il ya déjà des
traces au moyen-âge d'accord ça se
faisait à l'époque avec des petites
coquilles de noix
donc ça veut dire que potentiellement
avant que les cartes telles qu'on les
connaît existe ouais il y avait déjà du
bonneteau avec le temps des noirs des
petites coquilles de noix
bon il ya eu les palais tout ça enfin
pour en parler et il ya une gravure
d'ailleurs je suis sûr vous connaissez
tous lui reconnaissent le l'escamoteur 2
de jérôme lui certaines jeunes bosch
c'est jérôme bosch enfin et là on voit
bien on voit l'escamoteur avec ses
petits gobelets et donc les badauds qui
sont là qui vont se faire arnaquer
anciens et d'ailleurs ces gobelets on
les utilise actuellement bas au pied de
la tour eiffel
c'est ce qu'ils font les havrais abbas
en bas de la tour eiffel par l'armada
touré fait c'est ça alors c'est pas du
gobelet exactement comme cela tu vois
pas ce que ça c'est plus nous les
magiciens pour la halle du gobelet de
sel et l'eau glaciale dans les rangs
brillante c'est donc ratant prévention x
va nous faire voir les pleins de trucs
de bonneteau pour pas qu'on soit
arnaquer évidemment c'est surtout pas
pour vous apprendre à faire du bonneteau
non non non on aurait évidemment non
tous mais à ce jeu-là le bonneteau même
quand on connaît pas le nom on connaît
le jeu en lui-même on peut pas être
passé à côté tu dis depuis bosch on le
voit mais en plus c'est une référence
s'il ya un rapport intime au bonneteau
on le voit dans des films on voit dans
des émissions de télé on
en plein de films ça y est 3 yards on
voyait aussi depuis j'ai bu de fort
boyard
ouais donc en fait ça a toujours été un
truc de entre le magicien et le
charlatan aujourd'hui à notre époque
parce qu'avant c'était vraiment pour
gagner de l'argent les mecs qui jouent à
leur vie quoi tu vois clairement
aujourd'hui les mecs comme toi qui font
de la triche pour le divertissement bon
bateau tu prends l'argent sur le billet
d'entrée de ton spectacle c'est ça
exactement mais qu'ils obtiennent
vraiment un spectacle donc c'est pas une
arnaque d'assurance mais il en a fait
une question on se fait des petites des
mots je vais je vais laisser ma place à
quelqu'un à fanny travailler avec nous
au bureau que vous avez jamais vues dans
les vidéos ci dont vous avez l'instant g
dans la description parce que celle
qu'il faut aussi beaucoup de photos des
tournages à la dore faire des tournages
en provence sa passion ses dettes à la
caméra forcément si tu bois tu me fais
le bonneteau je connais assez les
techniques pour trouver donc j'ai pas
simulé de vous faire avoir ou tout ça
c'est vrai donc c'est on aura quelqu'un
de neutre de naïve
quand elle sait quand leur a bon bah
c'est que alors as réussi à te voir
octobre a voulu la faire gagner
et quand elle aura faut c'est qu'alors
info et elle l est pas comme vous et ne
peut pas faire arrêt sur image et met au
ralenti donc je pense que je lis déjà
vos commentaires je suis mentaliste et
je vois le oui j'avais vu ça t'es pas
prêt vous mentez vous mentez peut-être
pas toujours mais en tout cas vous vous
avez des moyens de refaire des retours
en arrière en live ça donne ça bon leur
famille on va jouer ensemble montrent
inquiètes pas je ne vais pas tarnac et
je vais pas de voler ton argent n'est
pas de problème on va juste s'amuser
c'est pour nous à bonne école et leur
montrer un petit peu comment on peut un
peu triché et puis surtout avoir des
excuses moi un pigeon
en fait le truc donc c'est de suivre le
roi de carreau d'accord donc là ici tu
vois ça c'est les cartes qu'ils perdent
et le roi de carreau qui gagne ok donc
là voilà ce que je fais au départ je
montre leur point de carreaux ici ça
perd ici sa paire attention j'ai mélangé
c'est relativement facile tu es là
correctement ou le roi de carreau est
évidemment toujours ou mises d'accord
alors ici sa paire d'accord ici ça perd
ici ça perd hélas ça gagne donc je vais
doucement
attention tac donc ça gagne sa paire et
sa paire hop hop tu te souviens aussi
gagnent au milieu et malheureusement
c'est encore gardés et non c'était la
cata d'accord mais mais mais on est bien
d'accord t'as une chance sur trois ce
que tu vas faire si tu vas devenir son
appel suspicieuse dire que tu vas
regarde tu vas suivre le roi de carreau
ok donc hop roi de carreau
sapers a peur pour toi ue il est au
milieu
ce que tu veux faire c'est tu vas
devenir suspicieux divers bon s'il n'est
pas au milieu il est peut-être là ou là
d'accord alors à ton avis tu vois ce que
gm pourrait être là et là bas non c'est
encore perdu c'est bien tap tap a choisi
de l'endroit où ils étaient ils étaient
là mais par exemple tu m'aurais dit
qu'il était ici c'est ce que j'aurais
fait jordi barre effectivement il est
pas là mais en fait si on vérifie il
n'est pas là non plus voilà est en fait
j'aurais encore tricher d'accord
j'aurais fait ce qu'on appelle un
changement xi qu'un donc en gros pour
vous montrer que c'est un jeu auquel
qu'on veut voilà on ne peut jamais
gagner quoi d'accord alors on va on
essayait l'indignation de fans et au
fait je perds ton temps
on va essayer un autre truc hein et là
tu vas être des rois ou super il offre
un superbe collier aime ça alors ça
c'est marrant parce que j'en avais parlé
à fabien
au téléphone et il m'avait dit mais j'ai
jamais entendu parler de ce truc là et
c'est vrai c'est vrai que
ça s'appelle ça s'appelle la chaîne
bugiste ans et ses vérités vous assure
c'est vraiment un truc qui se joue alors
les roues loges mais tout ça très très
vieux truc c'est exactement la même
chose avec ok je vais faire des boucles
et or l'idée pour gagner c'est de mettre
son doigt dans une boucle mentir là et
que ça c'est shine tu mets le doigt dans
une boucle nakheel il ya du suspense à
lui faire défaut at il dit j'ai gagné je
pas gagné et si fanni a gagné ça bouffe
année alors c'était pour tester c'est là
donc là le client et à pâte et ça marche
au delà là on dit tu paries 20 euros
flat on dit que famille paris 20 euros
et en plus je suis super sympa
est ce que je vais lui donner deux
chances qu'elle tu peux mettre un doigt
ici un doigt ici un peu essayé un doigt
ici comme ça
suspense je sais que nos internautes
sont suspendus à banaliser au taquet
hélas hélas à bloc a forcément
maintenant tu as le choix fans sur le
pouce soit l'index comme tu veux aller
tu gardes de pouzilhac et émana perd 10
et 20 euros
alors oui en fait la honte la chaîne du
gitan c'est pareil c'est pareil
impossible de gagner je vais pas vous
dévoiler le tout mais c'est une façon
dont la chaîne est déposé dans les looks
dessous fait vous ne gagnez jamais non
plus donc ça ne jouais pas non plus à
nous c'est vrai que fabien le disais les
magiciens on a quand même populariser ce
jeu le bonneteau pour faire rêver les
gens pourront faire inspecter et on
parlait de l'histoire du bonneteau c'est
vrai que au moyen-âge ça se jouait aussi
avec des gobelets d'accord et d'ailleurs
on a une description du bonneteau robert
houdin on avait parlé dans un de ses
livres
ça jouait pas avec une petite muscade
comme j'ai ici tu vois là ça se joue
avec ça avant petit muscade non en fait
ça se joue avec un indé ça c'est le
bonneteau d'origine ça c'est le
bonneteau d'origine c'est un peu bon il
y avait trois gobelets moi j'ai
simplifié le truc gémit qu'un seul
gobelet donc comme ça c'est plus facile
à suivre et tout devrait s'en sortir
ouais ok donc tu vérifies tient vérifier
le ça que ça c'est important rien au
fond ok je laisse le sac comme ceci
alors le truc très simple c'est que je
mets le des soul gobelet du couche de
colle des who et le défi ton avis et
bayer sous le double est évidemment pour
toi n'y a qu'une seule possibilité pas
en fait non il ya trois possibilités
siècle le défilé soit en fait il est
soit sous gobelet d'accord soyez dans ma
main soyez dans la poche donc à ton avis
ou ld je te donne un indice non non plus
non en fait il est dans la poche et les
tricheurs sont juste ça comme ça et
normalement ça marche un temps - refaire
et la normale voilà ça revient de
croquer ce qui est marrant c'est que on
se démentira pas examiné les progrès y
vérifie c'est bon ça va d'accord ok on
secoue un petit peu comme ça mais ta
main bien à plat voilà tu vas sentir
moralement le dé vous fait rêver dans
l'année va s'en tirer
c'est bien ça ok on va le refaire donc
maintenant tu te souviens je pose ici je
met dans la poche et donc où est le
deuil est maintenant il est saoul double
ça donc l'attend mais perdit sa encore
disparu oui effectivement tu te souviens
c'est sous le gobelet d'accord mais
souviens-toi qu'au départ je t'ai dit à
examiner le détail c'est minime gobelet
d'accord la question c'était c'est quoi
c'est lui qui est truqué où c'est lui
et en fait ce qu'un des deux c'est un
truc que tu as oublié
né en fait c'est ça c'est le voilà c'est
le sac études suède a émis à l'inde dans
pourtant d ouais je crois que t'as pas
bien examiner parce qu'il restait un
dernier petit truc c'était voilà merci
fans donc voilà ça c'est plus du
bonneteau pour faire rêver les gens pour
les bleus fait quoi d'accord attention
la suite de cette vidéo est à smr non
pas du tout ne vous approchez pas trop
près nous avons un petit problème de son
sur la séquence qui est en train de
défiler derrière vous le micro c'est
débrancher du coup le son est plus que
péter alors vous ratez rien concernant
le bonneteau et la triche néanmoins on
vous disait au revoir avec maurice donc
vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne de
maurice duda très qualitative en plus il
a sorti son propre jeu de cartes qui
vous en reparlera sur sa chaîne qui si
vous vous pouvez vous pouvez pas vous
pouvez quoi loïc vous abonner et super
accents abonnez vous à ma chaîne ici la
vidéo de la semaine dernière ici une
autre vidéo que j'avais déjà réalisé
avec maurice sur la triche
à très bientôt laïque et la vidéo aimez
vous les uns les autres ciao